Oilers now will get it ahead with five and a
half gone in the opening period for Evander
Kane played smartly there by Alex lion off the
kick plate to knock it away another big save oh
he got the left pad down and a toe on that did
Lion to keep it out and out of play Alex lion
doing what he's done this season when he's been
called upon barking on it again but then checked
by atol he came from Nashville last February
played through a hip issue to start the season
that didn't help the Oilers record either oh
a goal post that's the shooting some people
wonder if the Toronto May police have ever been
the same since they didn't sign Hyman flipped
ahead for fabri checked there by buard lift to
the stick and a good play by James Hamlin the
undrafted rookie brought to side in the short
side there by lion game break can mix so they
didn't need it but I'll show you my solution
to the problem when we get a whistle here but
meantime time the Edmonton Oilers are on a power
play and played back here for buard into the slot
big save Again by line another stop by line
this time with the blocker you'd have to look
a long way to see two better saves than these
two right here because the Puck's got to be all
the way out to be considered offside why does
it have to be all the way in to be considered
onside here's Kane with a shot up the goal post
oh my second time that post has been hit in this
game now by Patrick Kane not sure if that hit
the Stick of nurse or not to Brink it Petri
in for Kane tried to go back to confer comes
back to Kane short side boy he had to Brink
it going to the net with the goal tender on his
knees he actually he he wasn't down far enough
ma in the slot for fiser fiser
turning with it watch by Ryan tip
through at Center here's Christian
fiser he's got a break right the
goal penalty up coming will it be a
penalty shot let's see delayed call
here save off Raymond peron's got it checked by
Evan Bard back for Dylan Lin Lin to
Raymond and a save by Kelvin picker
McDavid back of the net finds de har and that gets
stopped by lion another shot in a loose
pocket that a stretch pass ahe for rash
mus rash M check Kane fiser came in picked up
by cop CP with room and a shot he scores his
first goal in in 27 games comes in an excellent
Time Red Wings lead it one to nothing well the
guy that got the winning goal on the road trip
is responsible for this whole thing happening
down in the corner 27 r m with that big size
protected the puck stayed with it kept it in
possession of a red jersey and this Puck went
off somebody in front of the net whether it
was a defenseman on the oiler side or not
it went off a stick there and I think it
went off a body right in front the Fisher at
the top of your screen now going towards the
goalie a come on all right we get another
angle look at this another angle look at this
the goalie's on the top of the crease Fisher
I don't think I don't think fer put his glove
into after video review it was determined that
there was no no go tender inter okay W that's
pretty clear cut yep ah Hadad for Kane from The
bricket Kane fabry hit the goal post oh are you
serious Fab thinks a 10 16 but this last one
is a shot why because Pickard got a piece of
that with his blocker or that puck in the nck
here's spraw for Kane wow another one off the
post for de Brink very carefully to know where
to what stick to grab and you don't just hand
a guy any stick super and Brady and Paul Boyer
the group great job into the slot save by lion
confidently cleared it away for Lucas R now no
cider without a stick they're at the ready with
one cider kicked it ahead oh is that too many
who jumped off and who came on nice move right
in on goal what a goal Conor McDavid and it's
a tie game w we got we got something going on
here what side you're rooting for you got to
love the skill and is that close to offside
they're looking at it they're going to look
closely at it I guess so did they tag up in
time before McDavid had possession but what a
move in tight Conor McDavid for now with his
16th goal of the season and a n game point
streak we were goalless through 40 minutes
first time this season the Red Wings an opponent
no scoring through 40 and two unassisted goals
first by op in by McDavid and here's a chance
and a save by R off Fogle picked up by De
brinkin here's Bard in for McDavid in
the slot for at another wow another shot
to score up high and Heyman buried
it two to one Edmonton with six to
play just scored his 26 six and his 22nd goal Mick
the last 25 games for the former Wolverine that's
certainly hot there's no question about that and
lion had no chance he never saw the puck just too
many bodies there's the stop he made right there
on the short side with his left pad and then with
all those bodies in front pman just ripped it at
the net and threw all that traffic finds the back
Sunday night at least you'll be watching the first
period in a bit with us here's dry Sidle across
for Fogle and a save by line didn't know where
it was boy they moveed that puck so quickly and
effectively cider with
it in for Raymond High Rising shot back to
the line kept in by Lin for Raymond Off the
Bench comes on in front of the goal
should they score bangs it in two two
tie wow it looks like it's off 25 there now take
a look at the Blue Line to make sure that Lin
kept this puck in if he did it was a great play
went off nurse's skate and bounc oh my goodness
cous
actually Raymond was going for David Baron and it
hit this the skate of Nerf and it was a
heck of a play by Dylan Lin at the Blue
Line stumped it dry Sidle plays it 20 seconds
to go on the hard Rim CeCe Ryan gets walked
there by sherat shot in front save by line
knock down by Ryan L they score a Vander Kane
but no goal waving it off oh boy why picked
up here by Bard again Drive Sidle that went
wide McDavid dry Sidle going off and left
there on the change back in for Heyman one
and one tonight Hyman to the goal loose Puck
knocked away right back to nurse he scores
32 Edmonton wins Darnell nurse the gamewinner in
overtime tie a club record with a ninth straight
Victory see lions got no
stick and that was because of what
happened right I'd have to see this
again almost looked like he he dropped
it when Heyman cut to the front of the
net I don't know if the goalie can use
a broken stick it's not a problem but uh